à faire une story instagram à dubaï avec
deux influenceurs en dix ans les frères
vous venez voir mon spectacle ça c'est
de la triche je préfère comme disait
benjamin que les gens viennent voir le
spectacle et qui dispute un le mec
j'avais un jugement sur lui eh ben j'ai
vu un truc qui m'a fait rire que
commencer à faire des amitiés parce que
pardon te dire ça il ya un joueur de
foot que j'aime beaucoup qui s'appelle
adil rami a dit que c'était pas les
ayants footballeur mais la réalité c'est
qu'il était très content avec les gens
dans le vestiaire et ça lui a permis de
gagner le coupe du monde ou bien comme
non mais je veux dire
mais puisque je les aime bien en plus
mais la réalité c'est dans l'humour
c'est pareil c'est que tu sais pas parce
que tu es dans une bande que forcément
derrière tu es quelqu'un de marans faire
rire les gens que les gens se déplacent
en plus avec une crise économique comme
aujourd'hui où ils vont donner 30 euros
ils vont aller dîner derrière ces 200
euros et que derrière tes pas drôle
je peux concevoir que les gens ce moment
ils en veulent à tout va des potes dans
le métier ou pas ouais bien sûr c'est
vrai quoi ton note à tête à balata
benjamin crasnier benjamin tranier c'est
au-delà d'un pote c'est voilà moi je
suis très bien à dire clanique
il ya des gens que j'aime vraiment
beaucoup je suis et même des gens avec
qui je parle peluches en embrouille moi
je suis hyper fier du moment qui font
carrière et qui réussissent n'y a pas de
rancoeur après il faut pas qu'on s'en
voir des vite alors j'aime beaucoup les
talent les collègues de paillettes les
gens ils savaient déjà existants d'aidé
affectif
on rencontre quelqu'un ose y mettant ses
horaires et je vais l'appeler à 2 heures
du matin j'ai crevé sur le périph il va
pas venir flammes voilà c'est pas nous
aiment pas aux vrais copains c'est celui
avec qui tu jouir d'un couteau tendu la
main ou pas du tout il a même et non tu
vois pas ce que ces publics mais par
exemple à jamel debbouze n'a jamais
proposé de faire le marrakech du rire et
c'est pas grave qui garde le marrakech
je sais où et marrakech je suis
marrakchi j'irai faire rire des blagues
l'a pas mais moi je vais pas dire à
jamel que c'est mon copain pour pouvoir
être marrant là bas